well let's let's let's let's first do
this uh you know this is a breaking
story
uh trump's campaign website is seized by
hackers who claim to have evidence that
proves his criminal involvement with
foreign actors to manipulate the 2020
election
of course as of right now his website is
back to normal we checked and so i saw
this and i was like whoa this this is
like
you know something's gonna come let's
let's let's launch with this and then
it's
just a big nothing burger these things
happen but the gist of the story is
his campaign website was seized by
hackers tuesday a message reading this
site was seized appeared briefly on the
homepage of donaldj
trump.com before the website was taken
offline completely just after 7 20 pm
the message continued that the world has
had enough of fake news
spreaded okay daily by the president it
is time to allow the world to know the
truth
the hackers behind the stunt claims to
have compromised multiple of the
president's devices
it seems like uh grammatical errors
aren't unique to the hackers daily mail
come on get a copy of it
that gave them full access to trump and
his relatives along with access to
confidential information
strictly classified information is
exposed proving that the trump
government is involved in the origins of
the
virus the post read we have evidence
that completely discredits mr trump as
president
proving his criminal involvement and
cooperation with foreign actors
manipulating 2020 elections
the u.s citizens have no choice okay
it's a nothing burger i i almost feel
kind of dumb that we even decided to
bring it up because i was like it was
like breaking news and i'm like oh wow
we got
what's going on i think you've got it
though same typos and the actual daily
mail writing end of the thing maybe they
did it
yeah the the inside scoop yeah there it
is perfect
we've we've busted nah they're making
the news
i gotta be honest daily mail has needs
to hire some copy editors so like you
know they have grammatical errors all
the time
of all the outlets you know there's
there's there's that
but uh we we so look that's that's the
gist of it
tim was it true what they were saying
that they were trying to blame trump for
the
covid crisis what's going on there what
the hackers yeah that's what i heard i
heard that they were trying to blame
trump for this and they were like this
is the big deal i mentioned earlier
is the u.s government and the chinese
government are all these governments
working together to create a bio weapon
in a chinese lab that then got out
that's like a movie script dude that's
just no i'm 100
behind it yes the incorrect well
half the the bad grammar kind of leaves
like
involved in the origins i mean i think
trump flubbed the coveted response sure
but
involved in creating coronavirus i don't
know like um
that that'd be a pretty sensational
claim right it's pretty ridiculous maybe
they saw borat they were inspired you
know
creative flourish but i don't know maybe
explain why they're gonna be watching
rammer was wrong
they made it put it in china so they
could blame china i've heard that it
wasn't just a chinese company working
out of that
lab like other where did you hear this
um i read it on the internet yeah
okay i read that it was like some
company that fauchi was involved with
was
working at uh i do i don't have the
documents
yeah i give up but but i met faushi he
admitted to it though it's true oh
really oh snap so so well let's let's
dive in you just said you think trump uh
you think trump flubbed
the response oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
i think i mean one of the problems is we
don't actually have a metric for knowing
what success looks like every
pandemic response is unique you know um
would hillary clinton have done better
or worse
the fact of the matter is america is its
own country no other country is a
perfect comparison
we also have a very decentralized
government states are given a lot of
autonomy when it comes to responses
which can be a downside when it comes to
stuff like this i think there were a lot
of things that he did wrong from a sort
of habitual tendency to downplay the
severity of the virus
we know of course that he was informed
of its severity but didn't want people
to panic
which seems like it was an effort to
keep stock investors from
sort of you know hard selling uh which
may or may not work we know of course
there was a crash later anyway
but the thing that bothers me the most
about the whole response is that i don't
actually think
there's a metric that republicans would
like a line where they would say that's
too many deaths
because right now it's at 225 000 ish
and i feel like and trump saying well
you know they said it was going to be 2
million which was the estimate if
nothing was done so what if it had hit a
million would they say well that's half
of what was expected if it hit 2 million
would trump have said
well that's exactly what they said was
going to happen
you could say the same thing with the
democrats or you know if it's right
versus left the democrats would not have
accepted
any number at all oh i mean and if they
were in power i'd be perfectly willing
to criticize for them absolutely yeah
but right now i mean we
this is i mean trump has had his hands
have covered this whole thing
it's true but it feels like then the the
real issue is
do you like trump or not i mean look 200
25 000 is
is really really bad it's horrifying
right and i mean even even trump has has
said that
we don't know what it could have been or
would have been there's no magic for
success which you pointed out
so it's either do you do you trust him
or do you like him or do you not well
there are things that he did that i'm
reasonably sure like a hillary clinton
and by the way please
for everyone i don't like hillary
clinton we can write that on my team
what about joe biden no no no no i'll
admit i do like him more than hillary
clinton i think he is marginally more
likely
than hillary clinton yeah hillary
clinton is the bottom of the barrel man
right right so
we're only nowhere to go but up oh my
god that's right
but um yeah so with trump when it comes
to stuff like for example
um uh downplaying the severity of the
virus i feel like democrats would have
done that to an extent
but when it comes to stuff like
habitually like
ignoring masks or like sort of arguing
with fauci back and forth to the point
where fauci now needs a security detail
to go in his runs because there are a
lot of far-right groups who think that
he's
trying to lock down the whole country
with him sort of promoting the
anti-lockdown protest saying they were
taking back the respective states which
has led to additional
threats of violence i feel like stuff
like that refers to a particular kind of
far-right populism that the democrats
don't have the ability to tap into
you know what do you mean i don't think
the democrats really have the same
base of fanatical support in the way
that the trump supporters do they have
now there are like key hive
lunatics and those people exist and
they're real but i feel like their
antagonism is more directed at
sort of uh uh chauvinism or
anti-progressivism or just
against any candidate their preferred
candidate doesn't like but this like
hardcore
ultra-nationalist rejection of
a national uh response to covet that i
think is a particular to the trump
fandom
what what groups like what right-wing
groups
are engaging in this kind of violence
and and going after people well the
violence is fairly
i mean a violence like political
violence is always going to be a fairly
small percentage of the actual harm done
here
no political group could ever do harm to
rival the 225
000 dead you know right but we tend to
wipe that stuff onto the rug
this is one of the criticisms that i
have as a libertarian socialist like
with the general system that we live in
you know
we'll say like news media will focus a
terrorist attack seven dead that's
horrible of course
but at the same time you know um
pharmaceutical companies are pushing
doctors to give unneeded opiates to
people and in the same period of time 13
000 people might die but that
that's a statistic that's not a news
story that just keeps happening
so what i'm worried about isn't the
actual political violence it's about the
attitudes we've taken that have allowed
kova to continue to this point
just today trump said well as one of his
like campaign achievements prior to the
election
conquering covet 19 on saturday
highest recorded number of cases in the
history of the country in a single day
they're horrifying
and mike mike pence has said i think he
said during the debate he tweeted and
deleted the tweet
that trump locked everything down which
is not the case
there's a lot of complicated stuff here
because we're going now from covey we're
getting to political violence
so i think the simple point i can make
which i did i guess is when it comes to
the coveted response
there's nothing to base it off of for
for me i'm kind of like okay well
early on trump took action very early on
like it was in january to form the task
force to to
suspend most to restrict most travel
there was there were some cases in which
people could travel from china
eventually to europe and anthony fauci
in march said no one could have done it
better
so that was the early response dr fauci
said don't wear masks
we had who was the surgeon general guy
don't wear masks they both did they
they tweeted about it fauci is now
saying it was a mistake for him to say
not to wear masks
there's a video that the republicans put
out where you've got kamala harris and
joe biden criticizing
things trump has said and then they show
that was fouchy was the one advising
like fauci was the one saying it
publicly
so in this capacity i i've been covering
this since it started and i remember
anthony fauci saying trump is doing the
best
i don't think anyone could do anything
better now we're several months you know
we're several months on we're getting
close to election and all of a sudden
everyone's saying trump has done a
miserable job
to be fair it's not all of a sudden i
mean there have been points where
fauci's and i disagree by the way i
think initially fauci's arguing you
don't need to use masks was
i mean the the the logic he used there
was that he was trying to disincentivize
the purchase of ppe that otherwise
needed to go to medical professionals
yes and i think it's irresponsible to
put that out saying
masks aren't effective or we don't know
masks are effective i think a more
responsible way would have been to sort
of implore
americans to be responsible with their
consumerism you know the weird
the weirdest thing about it is though
early on conservatives are the ones like
i'm gonna go buy masks
i was getting messaged by people like
hey don't listen to foundation go buy
your mask
and now all of a sudden yeah exactly but
it's but it's both
like you had you had democrats saying
don't wear masks and the conservatives
don't wear masks then it flipped at some
point
and now it's the democrats i should say
the left or whatever it is i don't think
it was that unanimous i think that for
the most part people were on board with
wearing masks and there was a brief
period where we were very concerned
about making sure there was enough
materials available for the for the you
know for the hospitals and for the
nurses and what have you
but even early on and fauci's in a
difficult position here
because i have a strong feeling that if
fauci was too critical of the president
he would be replaced for somebody
less so so dr atlas yeah yeah so if
fauci praises the president there's kind
of like that
okay how much of this is like the kid
getting patted on the shoulder by the
teacher and how much of this is like a
real political assessment you know
i don't know i just think it's a degree
of skepticism that we have to apply
with regards to the early response
though with trump though we know that he
defunded the cdc he eliminated
obama's pandemic response team he pulled
the 44 researchers out of wuhan who were
supposed to investigate the origins of
that virus and while he did stop travel
from china quickly
um he did basically nothing for the next
month before stopping it from europe by
which point it
i think we now know it was pretty much
too late what should he have done
i i think that um and i think that his
and he says this now like uh biden
called me xenophobic for walking down
china that's not true
biden called him xenophobic comma but
also
but he was responding to trump's tweet
sure but that's because trump is pretty
xenophobic when it comes to china if you
can lock down china without it being
like this weird
nationalist condemnation of china you
know you can just say like oh
they're going through their own stuff
right now um what what could he have
done i think obviously a lockdown from
europe faster would have been preferable
i think a um
regardless of what fouchy said you know
once it was known
that masks were available for everyone
that the ppe line was secure
he should have been very on board with
promoting their use instead of like
tacitly supporting the anti-lockdown
anti-massacre protests with his tweets
and most importantly i think he should
have laid out a national plan
to help states to guide states to give
the money necessary he did
to help them well he kind of held it
over some of their heads
it was like there was the three-phase
plan that he launched earlier in the
year
of like what to do and how to do it and
then he and then he did this press
conference where he was like phase one
phase two phase three
here's what you need i'm the president i
can't control the states now it's up to
the governors
sure but he but he can though like he
can there ca
you can do a national mandate you can
order national distribution of resources
and it feels like
and if we get down to the dates it gets
particular here but there were times
when it felt like
he was like blackmailing states with
support like
oh yeah i'll give you this i'll give you
this your hospital's need i'll give you
these resources you know
but you're doing so terribly lately just
recently he said i think this is one of
the debates you'll have to forgive me if
i don't remember the exact source
he said that um he didn't care so much
about aid
for some of the stimulus deals because
they would have gone to
high crime democrat cities and what this
suggests to me is the partisanship of a
president who is
going to give preferential treatment to
basis of support that he knows will vote
for him
doesn't really care so much is this
other groups uh i
respect your point i think it's
complicated uh in terms of trump's
ability to
accurately and charismatically convey an
idea i would say he lacks that
substantially but one of the one of the
issues with giving money to a lot of
these states whether he's legally
allowed to do it there's going to be a
lawsuit
you've got these jurisdictions because
we'll now move into sort of the
political violence stuff when we get
into what's going on in philadelphia
you've got these jurisdictions that are
cutting people loose over and over and
over again and the riots keep going
so why should i as somebody who is uh
you know i pay my i pay taxes in a state
not having these problems why should i
have those federal tax dollars go to a
state that's just
dumping it into a sinkhole so now what
we have is we have states that have a
budget crisis notably
new york is a really good example cuomo
said i believe it was last year god help
us if the rich leave
then you get ocasio-cortez leading a
protest in the financial district
which triggers i guess it was a catalyst
for amazon
saying we don't want to bring bring our
40 20 to 40 000 jobs here
which is 30 billion dollars over over a
decade so now you've got new york city
in a budget crisis and then they go to
trump and say bail us out
and then trump says no and particularly
because
you've defunded a billion dollars from
your police you had widespread writing
and looting that wasn't taken care of
you've used taxpayer dollars to put a
political message in the street
why should federal tax dollars go
towards what new york is doing when
they're acting extremely irresponsibly i
think there are a lot of issues being
conflated here first of all if we just
look broadly at like a state level we
know it's generally red
states who underperform when it comes to
the investment they need from the
federal government as opposed to what
they pay in taxes
in large part because red states tend to
have a smaller portion of their
population in big cities which tend to
be more
efficient economically but then like you
say so new york's an
in a tiff as it is undeniably um and
like ocasio-cortez and the marches and
the protests the blm protests uh have
caused an amount of damage which is
infinitesimal compared to like
um say for example the amount of money
that the new york city police department
spends every year on settlements from
police brutality or other miss
about a billion a quarter billion a year
which exceeds the damage done by any of
the protests and that's an every year
thing not a
uh an exorbitant you know like once in a
half-century civil rights protest thing
um when we're talking about the reason
why new york is struggling right now
it's undeniably because of the impact of
covet
and uh and i mean that's hurting
everyone new york is a massive city
which means that its supply lines and
its industries are going to be more on
the razor's edge when it comes to their
ability to support the population
like a farm in a bad economy can hold
itself for a while but eight million
people in a
dense urban network needs a lot of
support
and i i just when it comes to like how
why should i help these people i mean i
understand the frustration i guess i
mean
i grew up in california hold on not not
so much why should i help these people i
totally understand people of new york
need help for sure
it's more of uh if i give money to the
city to the government
are they going to light it on fire is it
actually going to go to help the people
or are they just burning money
well i i mean i don't i haven't looked
at their budget registry for the past i
imagine that most of it goes to people
but i mean when it comes to you said
defunding the police i mean that would
mean there's less money going towards
very high you know powerful institutions
in that in that city so i feel like if
anything that would aid in the
responsible allocation of those funds
what we're talking about right now
ultimately is
how much do you trust city governments
to support their people and my answer
unequivocally would be i absolutely do
not
but i don't think the solution to that
is denying them funds i think that's the
solution to that is a
grassroots organization or network or
uprising
that tries to make our government more
accountable to its own people thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you